BEN WEDEMAN: Land once lush
and productive is drying up.
In the delta of Italy's
once mighty river Po,
drought has struck.
FEDERICA VIDALI:
[non-english speech]
BEN WEDEMAN: 70% of
the crop is gone,
Frederica Vidali tells me.
If it doesn't rain, you can
see the plants are burning up.
But this year the
rains didn't come.
It's Italy's worst
drought in 70 years.
Her soya crop is all but gone.
The drought has impacted a
third of Italy's agriculture.
It didn't rain much during
the winter or the spring,
plus Italy is going through
an unprecedented heatwave,
those combined to
create the perfect storm
for Italian agriculture.
Five major food
producing Italian regions
have declared a
drought emergency.
ANTONIO BEZZI:
[non-english speech]
BEN WEDEMAN: Three generations
of Antonio Bezzi's family
have cultivated rice
ANTONIO BEZZI:
[non-english speech]
BEN WEDEMAN: We've never seen
a drought like this, he says.
ANTONIO BEZZI:
[non-english speech]
BEN WEDEMAN: Climate change
here isn't a myth, it's reality.
ANTONIO BEZZI:
[non-english speech]
BEN WEDEMAN: In
the last 10 years,
Antonio says, the
area planted with rice
has gone down almost 50%
as a result of drought.
Close to the sea there
is water everywhere,
but not a drop to drink.
In normal times this
is where the saltwater
reached in this river, about
three miles from the Adriatic.
But now, because of the drought,
because of the low level
of fresh water in the
river Po, the saltwater
reaches about 18 miles
inland, and that is having
a disastrous effect on crops.
RODOLFO LAURENTI:
[non-english speech]
BEN WEDEMAN: Rodolfo Laurenti
works for the local water
authority, which closely
monitors the flow and salinity
of water in the Po Delta.
RODOLFO LAURENTI:
[non-english speech]
BEN WEDEMAN: The moment of
real climate crisis, he says,
is 2022.
To ensure adequate
drinking water,
one local authority
has resorted to renting
expensive mobile
desalination plants.
MONICA MANTO:
[non-english speech]
BEN WEDEMAN:
Climate change means
we have to be ready for
emergencies like this,
says director Monica Manto.
Elsewhere the little fresh
river water still available
is used to save at least a
portion of the rice crop.
ROMANA MAGNO:
[non-english speech]
BEN WEDEMAN: But
climate scientist,
Romana Magno warns
it's too little and--
ROMANA MAGNO: It's too late.
What we can do now is
try to reduce losses.
BEN WEDEMAN: And as this
drought goes on the losses
will only mount.
Ben Wedeman, CNN, in the
Po River delta, Italy.